It's been nearly three decades since the release
of "Pulp Fiction," and it's still one of the
most beloved films of all time — even though
one of the lead actors' parents didn't appreciate it.
Here are some fascinating facts about
Quentin Tarantino's violent classic.
John Travolta joined the cast of "Pulp Fiction"
during a low point in his career. He started
out strong in the '70s, parlaying his success
in the TV smash hit "Welcome Back, Kotter"
into even bigger roles in films like "Grease,"
"Saturday Night Fever," and "Blow Out" — the
last of which Quentin Tarantino considers
one of his top three movies ever made. Regardless,
he hadn't made a movie like that in quite
some time when he got a call from Tarantino
in the early '90s. After the success of his
debut feature, "Reservoir Dogs," the filmmaker
had the clout to live out his dream and make
his idol a star again.
That's a very kind gesture, but the way Travolta
tells the story makes it sound almost creepy.
During an appearance at the Supanova Comic
Con & Gaming event in Adelaide, the actor
shared his tale of being invited to Tarantino's
house and discovering his collection of Travolta-themed
board games. Travolta said —
"He just had this fantasy of being with his
favorite actor and playing the board games
from that actor's movies."
Travolta, being a bit eccentric himself, found
this odd behavior thoughtful and charming
rather than unnerving.
"Pulp Fiction" is one of the most quotable
movies ever made, but few lines have stuck
in viewers' heads quite like the monologue
that Samuel L. Jackson's character Jules delivers
to his victims — eventually inspiring him
to leave crime behind. He claims to be quoting
scripture, specifically a passage he says
is called Ezekiel 25:17.
"And you will know my name is the Lord when
I lay my vengeance upon thee."
If you know how biblical citation works, you'll
notice Jules speaks for a lot longer than
one verse — and in fact, only the ending
of the speech comes from the source Jules
claims for it. The rest is a mishmash of Old
and New Testament, with sources ranging from
Genesis to the 23rd Psalm. It seems like a
classic example of Quentin Tarantino's irreverent
mix-and-match approach to writing — and
it is, but he didn't actually write the monologue at all.
Jules' speech actually comes from "Bodigaado
Kiba" — "The Bodyguard" in English — a
low-budget comic book adaptation full of crime
and violence. Starring the legendary martial
artist Sonny Chiba, a new narrated text prologue
was added when the film was released in English.
Right down to the bogus citation, it's almost
word-for-word identical to Jules' big speech
— although Tarantino naturally had to take
out the reference to Chiba's character.
"And they shall know that I am Chiba the Bodyguard
when I shall lay my vengeance upon them."
Tarantino would eventually get the chance
to work with Chiba during production on "Kill
Bill," in which the Japanese actor plays the
master swordsmith Hattori Hanzo.
Actor Eric Stoltz appears in "Pulp Fiction"
as Lance, the local drug dealer who supplies
Vince with the drugs that almost kill Mia
Wallace. In one of the film's most memorable
moments, he has to show the frantic hitman
how to revive her with a syringe of adrenaline
— but before all that, Lance is lounging
on the sofa watching TV with a bowl of cereal in hand.
The specific brand is the kind of detail most
directors wouldn't think twice about, but
it was serious business to Tarantino. He chose
Fruit Brute, the long-discontinued monster-themed
cereal that used to adorn grocery-store shelves
during the Halloween season along with its
more famous counterparts Count Chocula and
Frankenberry. The brand went out of regular
circulation eight Halloweens after its debut
and was soon forgotten by just about everyone
— except for Tarantino, apparently. General
Mills did eventually bring Fruit Brute back
to store shelves in 2013 to haunt your breakfast
table, but that was nearly 20 years after
"Pulp Fiction's" release.
This wasn't even the first time the director
snuck the discontinued brand into one of his
movies, as you can see a box of it in Mr.
Orange's apartment in "Reservoir Dogs."
For over 25 years, "Pulp Fiction" fans have
wanted to know just one thing: what exactly
is inside that glowing briefcase? All we know
is that Jules and Vince are willing to kill
for it — and even though they open it up
multiple times, we never actually see inside
it or get any hint other than the unearthly
glow.
"Is that what I think it is?"
"Mm-hm."
"It's beautiful."
That mystery is an essential part of "Pulp
Fiction's" lasting appeal, but Tarantino started
out with a much more concrete answer. His
early drafts with Roger Avary revealed that
the briefcase contained the same diamonds
that the hapless heisters from "Reservoir
Dogs" had been fighting to get their hands
on. Apparently, that was considered "too predictable,"
so the writers decided to leave it up to the
audience.
It's an idea that proves Tarantino steals
from the best. The 1955 film noir classic
"Kiss Me Deadly" also revolves around a mysterious
case, and we never see anything but a glow
coming from inside that one either. We know
that particular film was on Tarantino's mind
as he wrote "Pulp Fiction," as he told Sight
and Sound —
"I wanted [Bruce Willis' character Butch]
to be basically like Ralph Meeker as Mike
Hammer in [Robert] Aldrich's 'Kiss Me Deadly.'"
"Pulp Fiction" restored John Travolta's cool
when he was cast as the character Vincent
Vega. The man has cool clothes, cool dialogue
— and, of course, a cool car. Tarantino
certainly thinks so, as that's his own red
Chevy that Vince is driving.
According to Hot Cars, the director bought
the '64 Chevy Malibu Super Sport five years
earlier with the money he made selling the
script for "True Romance." It was part of
the Chevelle series — they were Chevrolet's
first muscle cars, and they became a favorite
for classic car fans.
That made it a tempting target for carjackers,
and the Malibu went missing from Tarantino's
LA home the year "Pulp Fiction" premiered.
The director probably assumed he'd never get
it back, but he did — over 15 years later.
In 2013, TMZ reported that the Malibu was
found. Its owner at the time wasn't charged,
which only seems fair — after all, it probably
changed hands many times since the original
thief got ahold of it.
There's nothing Quentin Tarantino loves more
than dropping references to other movies into
his own, and the twist contest in Jackrabbit
Slim's is full of them. On the Blu-ray release's
"Chit Chat" documentary extra, John Travolta
recalled that Tarantino showed him Jean-Luc
Godard's "Bande á Part" to pinpoint the vibe
he was looking for. "Pulp Fiction" references
one of its most famous scenes, in which the
main trio dance to the jukebox in a coffee
shop — but instead of music, there's narration
describing their inner thoughts. "Bande á
Part" obviously made a big impression on Tarantino
— after all, he named his own production
company "A Band Apart."
"Now I wanna dance, I wanna win, I want that
trophy. So dance good."
Fans of classic movies may also recognize
some of Uma Thurman and Travolta's moves from
an even more important classic of European
cinema. Federico Fellini's "8 ½" combines
fantasy and autobiography for a story of a
filmmaker battling creative frustration and
existential despair. He turns that dour setup
into a whole lot of fun, including a dance
sequence that looks an awful lot like the
one in Jackrabbit Slim's.
Most people probably don't notice these references
at first glance, but there's another move
that superhero fans might notice. At one point,
Travolta waves two fingers in front of his
eyes — which is the signature move in "the
Batusi," a dance from the classic '60s "Batman"
series starring Adam West.
Vincent Vega has a bad habit of going to the
bathroom at the worst times. When Butch runs
home to pick up his watch, he finds Vince
waiting for him and shoots him as he leaves
the toilet. Later in the film — but earlier
chronologically — Vince takes another trip
to the john and misses Jules' confrontation
with the stick-up artists in the diner. Both
times, he's carrying a copy of "Modesty Blaise,"
one of a series of spy thrillers starring
writer Peter O'Donnell's comic strip heroine.
Modesty was a former war orphan and international
criminal who does freelance work for the British
secret service.
Quentin Tarantino is obviously a fan, and
he nearly put his own stamp on the character.
At some point, Miramax bought the rights to
the "Modesty Blaise" series, apparently in
the hopes that Tarantino would make a big
screen adaptation. Nothing ever came of it
— so in order to keep from losing the rights,
the studio turned out a quickie direct-to-video
movie called "My Name Is Modesty." Variety
reported that the whole thing was thrown together
in 18 days, with a director who'd only been
on the job for a week before filming started.
Tarantino still hasn't shown any indication
of making his own Modesty movie, but he did
get a credit on "My Name Is Modesty" as producer.
If there's another monologue in "Pulp Fiction"
as memorable as Ezekiel 25:17, it's the one
Christopher Walken recites during his single
scene as Captain Koons. He arrives in a flashback
to Butch Coolidge's childhood to deliver the
boy's heirloom watch, along with its rather crappy history.
"He hid it, in one place he knew he could
hide something, his ass. Five long years he
wore this watch up his ass."
One of the watch's previous owners, Dane Coolidge,
died in World War II at the battle of Wake
Island — but not before entrusting the watch
to an Air Force gunner named Winocki. The
man's name seems like an odd detail to include,
so it's no surprise that Tarantino didn't
throw it in on a whim. It's a tribute to Howard
Hawks, the multitalented Old Hollywood master
behind movies ranging from romantic comedies
like "His Girl Friday" and "Bringing Up Baby"
to film noir classics like "The Big Sleep."
The younger director paid his debt to his
inspiration by placing the events of former
pilot Hawks' 1943 war flick "Air Force" in
the "Pulp Fiction" world, inserting John Garfield's
character into Captain Koons' story.
"Pulp Fiction's" non-linear storytelling was
revolutionary in 1994, thanks in no small
part to editor Sally Menke's Oscar-nominated
work. Moments from early on in the film that
seem insignificant gain new meaning once we
see what happens before them. Quentin Tarantino
didn't invent this style of storytelling — you
can see it in classic novels like James Joyce's
"Ulysses" and Kurt Vonnegut's "Slaughterhouse-Five"
— but he turned it from an intellectual
exercise to a crowd-pleasing gimmick. In the
process, he inspired hundreds of imitators,
from Christopher Nolan's backwards breakout
hit "Memento" to the intersecting plotlines
of Paul Thomas Anderson's "Magnolia."
But not everyone was such a big fan. In a
documentary extra included in one of Pulp
Fiction's DVD releases, Samuel L. Jackson
recalled —
"I remember my mom saying, 'Why didn't they
put the movie together right? [...] It was
jumping all over the place, back and forth,
you're dead, you're alive, you're back, you're
here!' I said, 'Ma, that's just how the movie
works.'"
Vincent Vega's name may sound familiar to
fans of Tarantino's first film, "Reservoir
Dogs." The only named member of the color-coded
crew is Michael Madsen's psychotic Mr. Blonde,
who's also known as Vic Vega. That's more
than just a coincidence — Tarantino envisioned
the two characters as brothers and wrote a
whole script exploring their relationship.
Madsen recently revealed some of the details
to The Hollywood Reporter: Vince and Vic would
have met up after being released from different
prisons and started a club in Amsterdam, neatly
tying into Vince's legendary discussion of
the city in "Pulp Fiction."
Unfortunately, other projects kept getting
in the way, and by now both Madsen and Travolta
are far too old to convincingly play their
own younger selves. The idea still resurfaced,
moving the timeframe from before the characters'
deaths to after and instead focusing on two
other Vega brothers who meet at their siblings'
funeral. For now, though, it looks like either
version will only ever exist in fans' imaginations.